all righty then it's time for drew's
news your daily spit shine of the good
news silver and with me at the desk is
the best co-pilot in the biz rassi ross
matthews
hi everybody hi
gorging green
love love love this outfit you are
giving me what am i giving you
varsity oh thank you professor okay
thanks i thought it was gonna be
football player but okay um like a book
and a pipe
darling um you're not wrong uh so cute
if this is a course you get an a if you
know what i mean hey teacher's pet
i never got a name um
well first up jennifer coolidge uh says
that her career has been revitalized at
least in part to ariana grande
interesting i know i love this i always
think give credit where credit is due or
share your theories i love this one
because jennifer coolidge i mean goss
gosh a christopher guest movie oh my god
oh ben and snap
she's been around
for a very long time but the hollywood
reporter says that she told jimmy fallon
that after ariana went on his show and
did this killer impression of her it
went viral and cool things started
happening but after that jennifer
reached out to ariana and the next thing
she knew they were co-starring in the
video
thank you next wow and then more
opportunities followed and now jennifer
is receiving huge acclaim for her role
in white lotus her career is
white hot red hot whatever red white and
blue hot
um and um i think this is fun well she's
having such a moment you guys watch
white lotus on hbo wow and she was
nominated for fight lotus yeah i loved
white lotus she's nominated for a golden
globe for it and rightfully so jennifer
coolidge is the best of the best i had
dinner with her one time what i know i
know not normal life but i was there and
you know you know what she was like in
real life uh exactly the way she is in
the movies exactly the way she is in the
movies she's just like that that's what
i was hoping you're gonna say and but so
nice and so talented and i love seeing
people who've been around been here just
have a moment you know and jennifer
coolidge is having that so congrats to
her i also love like just being like hey
like props to
you know you ariana and now they're
friends and making videos it's it's
great i love it i love it
all right next up you know it's been
hard to escape the whirlwind romance of
kanye west and actress julia fox you
guys been paying attention they've been
having major pda out and about but what
if i told you that allegedly they only
met
last month
stylist reports they are a perfect
example of the new dating trend called
hard launching it's when you go public
with a relationship right out of the
gate and to me it's a little dangerous
people they're not waiting to see how it
goes no they're just going from hi how
are you to boom we're instagram official
now drew thoughts
um i love this story so much
not necessarily because of
kanye and julia although it is a
fascinating sort of um it's like public
art almost unveiling itself exactly um
that being said hard launching is such a
thing that totally happens to people
completely and i think for a lot of
women it happens in our minds
wait in your how does that work like
i'll totally heart launch a relationship
like women have a very rich fantasy life
is like is it like that for men
i've never hard launched in my mind no
never once
i think women can't help themselves
so you meet someone there's an initial
spark and then you just you see the
vision of everything yeah you start
creating like scenarios in your mind of
like how this is gonna work and how
that's gonna work and before you know it
you're like all the way down the line um
but that's just my own personal thing
yeah but you're having a whole story
line in your head none of this is
happening like you know like you you
just met this person and now you've gone
on this emotional roller coaster in your
mind where you dated for a while they
didn't want kids oh no oh now i'm over
them it's 30 seconds later girl you're
exhausting me well that's hard launching
that's hard launching in your brain
hey ross you're totally right yeah and
uh oh gosh yeah okay well i guess that's
what i grabbed onto this story
[Applause]
but i do think it is kind of a
phenomenon in the real world having
nothing to do with my bizarre little
head
i love that we now have a term for when
people do
come out of the woodwork and just it's
so hard so fast and you're like whoa
well and because
there is a conversation to be had
because whether you are a famous person
or
your grandma and your aunt sandy follow
you on instagram when you go instagram
official with somebody it's a thing you
know and there's there's a communication
i mean willie and i were together over a
year and it wasn't till we were engaged
that we were comfortable sort of putting
it out there for people because i don't
know once you do it's not yours anymore
it's a different thing
you know
i love you oh
i love you
i love how different we are too like
i've hard launched and sabotaged the
entire thing in 30 seconds and you're
like i want to wait a year
because
it's no longer totally ours and sacred
anymore you're yeah i love you i love
you too i love our yin yang
[Music]